20:19 is coming to an end but before
that happens we're gonna take a look at
Sony see their highs and lows discuss
them what went well what didn't they had
a pretty interesting year I'd say right
they didn't show up to e3 they started
their state of playthings a lot of
people left a lot of higher-ups left and
their exclusives well I wouldn't say
they were they were weakened they
weren't as strong as previous years I'd
say yeah you can't you can't come out
with uh with with the big guns every
year that's true and it seems like
they're gearing up for PlayStation 5
which we got some info on that as well
but before we get into that Michael
highs and lows
ohyes for me on PlayStation 4's front I
would say well a personal favor of mine
was judgment I think that well that
that's a ps4 exclusive and that's out of
our GG Studios known for the opposite
series and yoga has traditionally been a
Sony or a PlayStation franchise and
they've branched off but judgment is ps4
exclusive and it's one of my standouts
for the year that was great
and also I I liked des training a lot I
know it's a divisive game and ferd there
are good reasons for why people's
certain people don't like it there are
things to pick out of that game that
maybe fall short of some expectations
but overall I think that that's a very
bold game as a whole I think it's giving
Kojima Productions the the opportunity
to do something that's genuinely
different and as a ps4 exclusive I think
it's it's something that's special and
of course no it's not gonna hit for
everyone but it's definitely a standout
regardless it's very different than
anything we've seen even when you look
back at Sony's much of a lot yeah right
that's why it's it's very different
Peter how about you highs or lows behind
des training and you guys said it all so
I'm not gonna waste any time the lows
though honestly I would say generally
speaking it was a very boring year to be
a PlayStation owner I didn't find a
whole lot of reason to have faith in
what I couldn't even say like what their
plans are for the future what I had to
look forward to days gone was just a
really strange release and yeah like I
still love my PlayStation and use it way
more than my xbox but 2019 is kind of a
dud for me and if I'm looking at Sony
yeah I mean overall I would kind of say
the same as much as I
that's stranding but there is a lot
going into the future right because they
did very casually just like yeah here's
what's inside the PS 5 it's got ray
tracing it can do this they can do this
and it was just kind of out of nowhere
sure was that there's a wired article
yes it came out as exclusive for Wired
so props to them and mark Cerny just
basically laid out a bunch of detailed
information and for us like Peter and I
are kind of I guess tech experts so we
we love that stuff and to hear about how
ps5 is going to reduce low times to like
less than a second like for today I
think mark Cerny point out an example
like 15 seconds to load into a place in
spider-man well that's like 0.8 seconds
on the PS 5 and that's because of you
know different hardware's solid-state
drives which has been a thing that's
exclusive to pcs are now going to be
part of the PS 5 and that's a huge
advantage I mean we've been able to like
put them in Playstations but Sony hasn't
done anything to itself take advantage
of I am for us right to make that a part
of the ecosystem and yeah looking ahead
like I don't know that I need stunning
graphics like beyond adding great racing
like I think I'm pretty happy with the
state of game graphics today and so it's
gonna be these things that make the
experience of gaming feel more modern
and more seamless that are really going
to be awesome yeah and to just casually
come out on a for an article to lay out
some of those details I think that's
also a bold move in way like they're not
they don't have PSX anymore they stopped
that last year and then come back this
year with that so you know it's like we
have this is the information that we're
gonna dull out for this year to let you
all know that next year it's gonna be
huge for PS 5 so that was a surprising
move this year for Sony yeah I mean and
you talked about no PSX no e3 this year
either which was which was a strange but
maybe not a super surprising move
considering that it seems like they
didn't have a whole lot they were ready
to show or they said I mean we've shown
you guys stuff the same things a couple
years in a row now we don't want to do
it again we don't see the point in doing
it again yeah I mean cuz what's left
right that we the big thing we know of
his Last of Us part 2 right and they
have what is it go sushi
yeah and then and then it'll be on to
the PS five right yeah there wasn't
really necessary thing necessary for
like PS x and even to be a t3 and they
did relegate last of us to last of his
part to revealing to a private event and
I guess like they can call their own
shots that's what it says to me that
when Sony pulls out of III and they have
their marquee games to their own private
events it shows that like you know we we
at least of what it communicates to me
is that we can do these things on our
own we don't need to be part of the
grander stage because I didn't know
they'll create their own yeah but how
about those state of plays the kind of
things that have like in the place yeah
rough start you know first time the
entire levy are focused or at least
close to it and it was like I don't know
but you know they at least have some
ammunition to work with and I think they
proved that when they talked a lot about
Final Fantasy seven I think there was
one month or two ago where we just got a
ton of new info on that game so it's
been interesting to see them go about
that and improve upon it I I kind of
prefer it like I think I had we all have
some romanticism around e3 right and
what that represents but I also like the
idea of every month or so
getting hype about hey here's some
announcements coming I think Nintendo
has proven to be better at making those
moments feel like they are paying off
i've sony can figure that out that'd be
really good for them honestly because it
it it pays to know that you can sort of
have that engagement with a brand or a
platform that you're engaging with right
like on a regular basis sure and like
the other major platforms half at like
the like you mentioned Nintendo Dragon
Nelson doing his thing yeah inside Xbox
and now there's so many state of play
yeah they started out this year and it
it kind of shows that these platform
holders kind of you know with the advent
of the ease of streaming and doling out
that information like not every state of
player direct is going to be this major
thing it is a way to get out the word
for smaller announced announcements
maybe which we saw with the early state
of plays but concrete genie is an
example of that which is a game that
seem that seem to review pretty well
which I think that's like a good
announcement for something like that
yeah it kind of in a way I see state of
play and direct these streaming
information these information streams as
kind of leveling the playing field
between the big triple a games and some
of those smaller maybe smaller dev teams
and the games that they're making for
the platform so relegating will all that
the state of play is kind of gives
everyone an even playing field and it's
nice to see smaller games get that sort
of recognition or platform to say hey
we're out here we're coming out soon so
I guess to look ahead then a little bit
if this year was a little bit slow next
year supposed to be the PS 5 are you
guys thinking that next year could be a
very big year in terms of exclusives
maybe launch titles well if you look at
the ps4 launch I was pretty
disappointing I think the best game on
there was a resogun which hey nothing
against resogun it's a great game but
there was a lot of stuff that just felt
like maybe Sony ok that's a lot too soon
I don't know I never want to you know
we'll never be yeah I wasn't exciting
yeah and we don't know a ton about
what's on the way for ps5 even when it's
coming out state of play would be a
great opportunity for Sony to say like
this console is coming and these are the
games you're gonna get but you know
we've we've been burned by nak before
could another thing like that happen
again
certainly I mean who knows but a new
consoles always exciting I think the the
the kicker is that by by all accounts
that PS 5 is going to be backwards
compatible yeah
so Simon Oil right yeah you know like
the ps4 didn't have that with ps3 games
so there was there was a gap there you
know history kind of did early on but
they eventually like different models
you know so having the PS 5 come out and
say ok we have because next year they're
gonna come out with with last was part 2
and if people aren't able to play on PS
5 like that would kind of be
disappointing but you know we we know
that PS 5 to be back in pet and that's
very important for so many high-profile
games that are gonna come out soon or
that are already out so that kind of
props up the PS 5 as a you know you can
still get some of the benefits of this
hardware while playing all of those
games that are just had recently come
out
yeah I think for both console
manufacturers who are heading into a new
generation it's like the second
generation of this x86 console existence
and as we've see in the PC space you
know you just upgrade Hardware the old
games still work and you can make them
look better because you can tap into new
settings there's been no word of this
but I'm really curious if games are just
going to be automatically able to play
on PS 5 and automatically it's just like
changing graphics card settings right to
make that game look better yeah who
knows but I'd love to see that but and
before we leave the
backwards-compatibility part of it
that's gonna that is a huge part of
PlayStation now we know Sony is making a
big deal about cloud streaming going
ahead they cut the price of PlayStation
now in half this year which is
significant it still doesn't perform I
think in the way that people or at least
that game streaming is marketed to us as
but they're making moves certain and
that's gonna mean probably being able to
play ps3 or whatever ps2 games even like
on your PS 5 no PlayStation now has made
strides because I remember back when I
was looking into it to play ps3 games
like oh ok yeah their PS now is the way
to do it if I wanted to out my ps4 but
now it's it's come closer to kind of
what you know Xbox game pass and X cloud
is trying to do there's a ton of games
like I think there are like a few
hundred games yeah and you can even play
them on your PC like I have a
Playstation out client on my PC where I
can play that stuff yeah it's just a
matter of does it work well enough for
me to want to do that versus play the
actual thing yeah not quite there yet
better and to have the options cool yeah
they have to make improvements on that
and and it they they're show somebody
showing that they do care about that
sort of thing even like the big story
about how Sony's teaming up with
Microsoft to kind of shore up their
their cloud technology for gaming and in
the wake of Google stadia it kind of
shows that a sony 'm looks at Microsoft
like hey we need to kind of cover our
own ground because a lot of the games
that come out on ps4 and xboxone are
third-party games that are
multi-platform so I mean you can't have
game streaming as a service unless you
have the dedicated servers to do it so I
think for Sony they're looking at two
options there it's either they team up
with Amazon or they team up with
Microsoft not surprising to me that they
wouldn't go out of the gaming space and
team up with a behemoth like Amazon so
hey yeah why not just rent Microsoft's
Wade's if that's what they're really
doing it could be that simple yeah so
overall I think PS now is it may have
been kind of under the radar but in 2019
PS now has changed drastically yeah so
big picture overall what do you think
well how how is Sony in 2019 I was
alright you know it's there there's
there are things that I still care about
that showed up on on the ps4
like I mentioned judgment and you know
death stranding and I think I I'm
interested in cloud gaming as a whole
just to see where it goes and to see
Sony make those strides NPS now is it's
kind of an exciting prospect so those
are some of the things I mean like I
said you're not gonna have to play big
blockbusters in 2019 but that's alright
so I think that's pretty alright Peter
how about you in my mind I think the
only thing saving 2019 from being a less
than good year for Sony was des training
I think that that was a really exciting
is a really exciting game and really
does bring to light how important
exclusives can be for a company and for
you know people who only have one
console right to make it feel like they
made the right choice I don't know how
to put that but you know what I mean
yeah I I agree and I and I think we saw
this with Xbox too or we were talking
before it seems like this is very much a
transition year or it's getting close to
a transition year where these these
first party publishers and developers
are kind of slowing down maybe saving
what they're working on for what's to
come in the future of course which is
exciting for the future but it doesn't
help this year a whole lot right
anyways that's that's how Sony was in
2019 make sure stay tuned because we
have plenty of Game of the Year coverage
coming your way
you